YASMIN GREEN: Hello,
welcome today.
My name is Yasmin Green.
I am the Head of
Research and Development
for Jigsaw, which is
Alphabet's think tank
and incubator looking at
global security challenges.
I am very excited to introduce
as our guest speaker today
a longtime friend of Jigsaw,
formerly Google Ideas.
I wanted to actually
share a personal tidbit.
The day before yesterday I
was talking to my husband
about our shared beliefs.
You know, other people describe
their religion as Christianity,
or Judaism, or Hinduism,
or Scientology, or Orthodox
Freudian, or whatever.
And I was like, how would I
describe what our shared belief
system is, what kind of shapes
our behaviors and our values?
And we decided that
we're going to write out
kind of our version of
the Ten Commandments, so
the imperatives that
govern us, not just
spiritually and morally but
also political, societal,
technological.
And I realized that there
was so much there that
is broader than what we
necessarily think or, you know,
what we conventionally think
of as to do with religion.
I think that's a good segue to
introduce Parag Khanna today
because he is bringing
together those factors,
these multi-dimensional factors
and reimagining things that,
really around our world order
and our governance system.
And he's kind of
reimagining our future
with a much more nuanced
and complex framing
than we're used to.
So I will introduce him.
I'll give you a little
bit about his bio.
Parag is a international
relations expert, intellectual,
bestselling author.
He has just written a book
called "Connectography--
Mapping the Future of
Global Civilizations,"
and we are very
fortunate to have
some copies here at the
back so go and collect yours
on your way out.
Parag is CNN's Global
Contributor, a Senior Research
Fellow at the Center on Asian
Globalization at the Lee Kuan
Yew School of Public
Policy at the National
University of Singapore,
co-founder and CEO
of Hybrid Reality, which
is an advisory firm looking
at the policy
implications of the policy
and economic consequences
of emerging technology
and the co-founder and CEO of
Factotum, a boutique content
strategy agency.
Many of you may have
seen a Ted talk by Parag
or read one of his numerous
op-eds in "The New York Times."
You are unlikely to have read
his book already because it
just came out this morning.
So I thought we'd
structure today
with Parag giving us a
short presentation on some
of the key themes of
his book and then we
will sit down and
have a conversation
and have some Q&A. So
without further ado, Parag.
PARAG KHANNA: Thank you.
All right, good afternoon,
everyone here in New York
and at the Googleplex out there.
I'm told I should look at the
camera a little bit as well.
Thanks to all the
friends for being here.
Thank you, Yasmin-- a
dear old friend indeed.
And it's nice to see just
how enormously, exponentially
this office has grown and
congratulations, of course,
on becoming Jigsaw and all the
great things that you're doing.
So we were having
little conversation
earlier about how
to structure this
because even if you
haven't read the book yet,
you've probably
seen it over there.
And you see that it's
about 500 pages long.
So I have a presentation
lined up here,
which is so heavy in
megabytes, it almost
toppled the computer over.
So you get to vote.
Do you want lots of
text and notes and data
or do you want lots
of pretty pictures?
AUDIENCE: Pictures.
PARAG KHANNA: Pretty
pictures, right?
Yeah, that's what I thought.
OK, pretty pictures.
I think that'll be good for
the audience on the West Coast
as well.
So I'm going to speed through
the thesis of the book
and just give you a flavor of
things by way of talking you
through some of the maps
because the maps are really
the crown jewels of this book.
What you'll find is that
we have two map inserts
in the book, and
almost as much effort
went into producing those
as into the 120 something
thousand words of
the book itself.
Perhaps it was so
long because it's
the completion of a trilogy.
The first couple
books, actually, I
presented at the other
of Google office--
at the Googleplex-- doing
Authors at Google there.
So here I am fittingly
on the East Coast
to launch the completion
of the trilogy.
So we had to pack a lot
into this final book
because there won't
be anymore after this.
So get this one now.
I'm done.
I've got nothing left to say.
But there are lots and lots
of maps that really help
you explain the 21st century.
And I want to just emphasize
that all the maps in the book
and that I'm going
to show you today
are completely
bespoke and unique.
You've never seen
them anywhere else,
and they are from an
objective standpoint--
because I didn't make them.
I helped to design
and strategize them.
But they are,
objectively speaking,
having now looked at the whole
survey of global cartography,
they're the best
maps you will ever
see ever about the geographic
and infrastructural world.
So I consider them, as I
said, the crown jewels.
I'm going to talk you
through some of them.
So the first is this.
This actually isn't
from the book.
This is a screen shot from my
TED talk from a few weeks ago
in which I really talked
about the global connectivity
revolution, which is also
the thesis of the book.
It's effectively saying
that all of the maps that
hang on your walls
and our walls,
I accuse them all
of being completely
wrong and biased and
misleading because they always
show us the political
boundaries as the primary lines.
They tend to ignore completely
infrastructural lines.
And yet, the irony
being that we have
150 times more mileage
of infrastructure than we
have mileage of borders.
We have less than
500,000 kilometers
of borders between
countries, and we
have something on the order
of 75 million kilometers
worth of what you
see here, which
is highways and railways-- so
transportation-- oil and gas
pipelines and
electricity grids-- which
is energy-- and of
course, internet cables--
communications.
And that's just the beginning.
This revolution that I'm
talking about already
utterly overwhelms in terms
of how it unfolds itself
on the map of the world.
It actually totally overwhelms
our political divisions.
And yet, we're just
in the early phases
of building out the planet
through these transportation,
energy, and communications
infrastructure.
So I like to cite Autodesk-- the
design engineering firm-- that
says that we'll build more
infrastructure in the next 40
years than we have in
the last 4,000 years.
So this revolution
is just underway.
The spending that we're
going to put into this
amounts already to $4 or
$5 trillion dollars a year,
which is double what we spend
on all the military and defense
establishments in the world.
So I think that this
is the beginning
of a great shift in the world.
And I want to set out to map it.
And I believe that it
requires, if you really
take this infrastructural
development
to its logical
conclusion, you literally
have to re-imagine how life is
organized on the planet Earth.
We always think of ourselves--
we're raised and trained--
in this epoc since
the 17th century,
basically, to think of ourselves
as being organized according
to countries.
Who you are is where you are and
where you are is in a country.
And your identity, therefore,
is that national identity.
And I really want to push
the envelope here and say
that, in fact, we are
organized much more according
to our infrastructure and our
supply chains and our cities.
So instead of
nations and borders,
we live in a world of
infrastructures, cities,
and supply chains.
And those matter and
shape who you are,
what you are, what you do,
and your potential outcomes
in life way more than just
what your national identity is.
And that contradicts
the oldest adage
that we know that all children
learn in school, which
is that geography is destiny.
And I'm arguing that's not true.
I'm arguing that connectivity
has now become destiny.
Connectivity is a lifeline.
It's an opportunity.
And it also creates multiple
sources and possibilities
for your identity in
ways that we're just
starting to appreciate today.
And this infrastructure,
what's so
fascinating from an
engineering standpoint,
there's a term that's
little used that I think
is going to become more
prominent these days,
and its topographical
engineering.
And so I actually open the book
with a travel around the world.
Imagine that you could
travel around the whole world
without leaving the ground.
You can do so through all
of the new railways and very
large floating
structures-- there's
an acronym, VLFS, in the field
of oil and gas engineering.
We're building
these floating oil
rigs that are larger than
the Sydney Opera House.
Even cruise ships
that size, we're
infrastructure able
to modify the earth.
So you're familiar with
this term anthropocene--
this age in which mankind's
impact on the ecology
on the planet become
so systemic that it
changes the nature of
the global environment.
And how have we done that?
We've done it through
this incredible revolution
in our durable
engineering capability.
So we're physically
constructing and reconstructing
and modifying the earth through
all this infrastructure.
And all of those infrastructures
are so much more durable
than our nations and
states and boundaries.
As I point out
repeatedly, we've had
cities-- cities are
the infrastructure
that you can see from space.
You can't see countries
and borders from space.
You can see cities.
You can even see railways now.
You can see tall buildings.
You can see all sorts
of man-made things.
You can't really see borders.
They're actually
much more artificial
than the infrastructures
that we build.
And cities outlast every
empire in every country that
nominally governs them, right?
We have had cities
for 5,000 years.
We've had Baghdad.
We've had a Constantinople--
now Istanbul.
And we've had Beirut and
Alexandria and so forth.
The countries that
seem like they
are the bedrock of our
international system,
legally, are actually fairly
insignificant in comparison
to the long histories
of our cities have.
And now the connectivity
between those cities
is becoming so robust
that we are becoming
what I call "a global network
civilization"-- not a world
in which states and the
relations among them
actually operate the system.
It may seem like that if you
look at an organizational chart
of the UN.
But because you're looking at an
organizational chart of the UN,
you think that that is
how the world works.
If you look at the world
itself, from the outside,
you would be seeing this.
This is the real world.
This is how the
world actually works,
not the way institutions
are structured.
And this is truly global.
We've never lived in a
world where world trade is
so all-encompassing and
where all the continents are
included in that system
on relatively equal terms.
You could have, obviously--
in the colonial era,
you had the dominance
over the developing
countries in the
southern hemisphere
by a few European empires.
Today, you don't have that.
Today, you have these growing,
dense continental economic
systems that are
increasingly tied
to each other by infrastructure
and by supply chains.
The same thing is happening
in capital markets.
So what it means is that this
world of nations and borders
is much more one that I
call a supply chain world.
And it's a world
that some described--
the physicist, Michio Kaku,
calls it perfect capitalism.
In a world where everything
is totally connected,
you unite all of these
historical forces
that economists and
sociologists have been talking
about for hundreds of years.
You bring together Adam Smith's
free markets, David Ricardo's
comparative advantage, and
Emile Durkheim's division
of labor-- Durkheim
is my favorite.
Ricardo Haussmann
from Harvard who
talks about a complexity
of production.
And you can achieve what
economics is really all about,
which is the optimization
of land, labor, capital,
and production.
And of course, you
do so in a way that
isn't organized according to
territorial political units,
but anywhere where you
want to produce something,
you can do so.
So like I said, I want to get
more into some of the maps,
and I want to talk about
what the supply chain
world of total
connectivity looks like.
Well, it's a world
in fact where we
have very substantial
mobility of people.
Globalization-- and this is
a book about globalization--
is ultimately all about people.
The history of
globalization begins
with mankind's wanderings out
of the African continent 60,000
some years ago, and it
hasn't stopped, obviously.
It continues unabated.
So today's headlines
are dominated
by Donald Trump
wanting to put up
a wall or European
populist politicians
talking about wanting
to close borders.
But the fact is that
that is a reaction
to the enormous amounts of
migration that have taken place
and continue to take place.
That is not the reality
of closing borders
or of pushing migrants
back because that actually
hasn't happened.
Europe let in one million
migrants in the year 2015,
more than ever before.
So that's talk.
The reality is this enormous
expansion of migration,
such that there
are 230, 250, some
say 300 million people
today living outside
of their country of origin.
They might be even
permanent expats.
And little do many
people in America
realize that there are more
American expats than ever
before.
Nine million Americans who
live outside the United States.
That's more than double what
the normal, standard amount
has been over the
last 10, 15 years.
So it's all shot up.
So we've become a
world, if you will,
of global economic migrants.
Everyone is wondering
either from the countryside
in the cities, across
borders, from one city
to another city in
search of a better life,
in search of
economic opportunity.
But it continues unabated.
And I will put my money
on this continuing.
Because in a supply and demand
world, rather than a nations
and borders world,
countries actually
wind up thinking
pragmatically about what
their needs are for
their economies-- what
their demographic needs are.
And the same places that
are talking about putting up
walls and borders
are the places that
actually most need immigrants.
Countries with aging populations
like in Europe and the United
States.
So I think that we
need to differentiate
between the short term
populism of politicians
and the long term
realities of a world
in which connectivity
facilitates migration.
More passports have visa
free access around the world.
Again, there are going
to be more frictions.
We can see that happening
right now with legislation
that Congress has passed.
There are more frictions,
yes, for security reasons.
Smart sensible frictions
are not a bad thing.
They help to prevent everything
from pandemics to terrorists
from entering a country.
But by and large,
those frictions
don't slow the overall
pattern of migration flows.
So this is another way of
rendering it and showing
just how many people are
moving around the world
within and across and
amongst the continents.
And it shows you not
only how important it is,
how systematic it
is demographically,
but how important
it is economically
in terms of the values
of the remittance flows.
And so there's an enormous
two-way benefit, of course,
to global migration.
Some economists
argue that you could
double world GDP by listing
migration restrictions.
I think that may
not be too far off.
I'm going to jump ahead a
little bit because I don't want
to take too long, but I want
to show you some of the maps
that I think are more accurate
representations of how humanity
is organized.
And this is one of them.
What's captured on this
map and not captured
on any conventional map
that hangs on your walls
is quite a few things.
First of all, you can
actually see people.
You don't just see artificial
states and boundaries.
What you see is every single
human being on the world
is on this map.
And yellow being the
most dense geographies.
Then, most importantly,
you see the dotted ovals,
which show you the largest
or most economically
significant urban clusters.
So you see Silicon Valley there.
And of course this
northeastern megalopolis,
where we're the
midway point here
in New York between
Boston and Washington.
You can see clusters like
Sao Paulo or Johannesburg,
South Africa, Lagos,
Nigeria, and so on and so on.
And you can also see just
how they are not only
the most important anchors
of their national economies,
but even entire regional
economies depend
on just a couple of cities.
So shown a different way,
this is the projection
until the year 2030.
I looked at the data of
projections by the World Bank,
by the United Nations-- all
sorts of organizations--
about what are the
main mega cities that
are emerging either today or
in the next 10 to 15 years?
If you want to be
megacity in the year 2030,
you would actually already
have to be well on your way
today, right?
So we can say with
some certainty
that this is not only
the map of today,
this is also the map of 2030.
I don't think in the
year 2030 I would
need a different
PowerPoint slide than this.
Because this is
already the areas
with the most dense
concentrations of populations
in the world.
And these cities are
so significant, again,
economically that
I think if you want
to understand the map of the
world in the 21st century,
you're much better
off just looking
at these cities and the
connections between them
to understand how the
world really operates.
So I coin this term
connectography.
By the way, no one says this
with more beautiful accent
than you, Yasmin.
But the other term
that I come up
with in this book
is diplomacity--
the diplomacy among
cities is ultimately
more revealing about
how the world operates.
Think about mergers
between stock exchanges,
think about nonstop
flights connecting
any two cities in the world.
It seems like Emirates
Airlines wants
you to be able to fly
around the world nonstop.
They're flying now
to Panama City,
to Auckland, New Zealand,
pretty soon the Sydney.
So this point-to-point travel.
Obviously, the data networks and
internet cables linking cities
and so on and so on, you
find that the relationships
among cities tell you
almost most of what
you need to know, in a way,
about the day-to-day reality
certainly of the world
economy and world society.
So how did places get there?
We often think of economic
growth as just an accident
or a byproduct of demographic
expansion, but in fact,
over the last 50
years, what countries
have started to do is to
strategically urbanize,
not just accidentally urbanize.
And they do so by creating
these special economic zones.
So what I've been tracking
is how in the last 50 years
we've grown from a world
of the three or four
or five experimental special
economic zones like Mauritius
or the Dominican
Republic or factory
towns and industrial
parks and clusters
within them-- and of course
Shenzhen in southern China.
Now you have 4,000 of them.
So how did Vietnam
get to be Vietnam?
How did Vietnam go from
being a country that
was so heavily bombarded and
fought against the United
States in the Vietnam War
to what it is today, which
is considered the next China
industrial powerhouse--
the Germany of East Asia?
How did that happen?
Well, it happened because
they copied the China model.
They designated
dozens or hundreds
of these industrial parks
in special economic zones.
They started attracting
investment and supply chains
and technology.
They started moving workers
there and training them
and ramping up their exports.
That's how they
did it, and that's
what country after country is
doing around the world today.
And I like I said,
there are 4,000
such special economic zones.
So they're not on our maps,
which is another reason why
our maps suck.
So I have a line
in this book where
I say I've spent the last five
years going to places that
apparently don't exist because
I don't know why they're not
on our maps, but the
locus of economic activity
in most of the world's
emerging economies
are these cities and special
economic zones that don't even
make it onto the maps.
And yet, they really should.
So what I've done
is to insert them
visually in a number
of maps in the book.
Entire countries are
reorganizing themselves
around urban clusters, and even
the most ancient civilizations
in the world, such
as China, that
have millennia of unique
cultural and provincial and
linguistic histories are
saying, wait a minute.
In order to be viable and
competitive economically,
we have to not
just have this kind
of historical,
cultural geography.
But instead, we need to have
a strategic urban geography
of highly populous, dense,
economically-productive,
and connected urban zones.
So in the New York
Times this weekend,
there was a two page map
that I worked with them
to produce that talked about
how America should do this.
The United States should
literally reorganize itself
around seven or eight
mega-regions that
have similar economic profiles
around the white zones, which
are the urban hubs
that either are
between or in the heart
of those regions that
are their financial
and demographic
and infrastructural centers.
And then, the lighter lines are
the high-speed railway networks
that would connect
those cities together.
So you would move from the
United States of America
towards the United
city-states of America.
Now, let's bear in
mind that I actually
softened the argument for fear
of the backlash against it,
but the feedback on this has
been so positive that I wish
I'd gone back and doubled down
on the argument in the op ed
and said, actually,
the 50 states
are literally pretty useless
other than for what's
happening right now, which is
collecting electoral votes.
But after that, after you've
won this primary or that primary
and made it into
the White House,
what does that mean
for the competitiveness
of the entire country
that you have to govern?
And it turns out the 50 states
mean absolutely nothing.
They certainly cause
a lot of friction.
I've gotten so many emails from
people in the last 48 hours
saying damn right.
I live in the tiny
state of Rhode Island,
where we have 30, 40
counties and we duplicate
our education and our
sanitation and all
these layers of bureaucracy.
And all that does is waste
money on politics rather than
on productive,
commercial activity.
So I feel even more
strongly about this
than I did four days ago
before this was published.
There's a lot more to say
about this, not only here
but also in the book.
So more of the re-mapping.
I want to point out the entire
world is remapping itself.
Region after region is building
infrastructure across borders
such that if you
were to map that, you
would get a totally different
appreciation for how
entire continents operate.
This is my map of the
North American Union
in which you can see that the
United States gets electricity
from Canada.
There's all of these railways
and energy and pipelines
and freight railways between
Canada and the United States.
The US is investing heavily
in the Mexican energy system.
It's doing joint production
of automobiles in Mexico.
San Diego and Tijuana now
share an airport terminal.
All of these things--
and eventually,
the United States
is going to need
more and more Canadian water.
The Canadians don't really
love this idea-- there's one.
The token Canadian.
Oh, two.
I'd say, statistically,
it's about right.
The point is that in
a world-- actually,
let me fast toward a little
bit and get right to it.
But some of these maps show you.
So Southeast Asia
is graduating from
this post-colonial geography
of 10 different countries
into one that, again, is densely
infrastructurally connected
the way that Europe is.
Africa, in the pathway out
of that scarred colonial map
of Africa with borders
organized according to latitude
and longitude, is in fact
building more connectivity
so that African
countries can more
seamlessly export their
goods together and scale
their economies.
That, I think, is a
very important pathway
out of thinking about the
future of the Middle East.
You have the
spectacular collapse
of the modern Arab state.
It didn't last very long.
And the post-colonial
decay of countries
that were born out of the French
and British empire in the 1940s
has been an obsession
of mine for a long time.
It traces its way
through all of my books.
And this is finally a time where
I say, OK, so what comes next?
What do you do in
the post-Arab Spring?
You can't really pretend that
Iraq exist or will exist again.
You can't really
pretend the same
for Syria or for any
number of other countries.
But let's go back to
the fact that the cities
of the Mesopotamian
region in the Middle East
are the oldest cities
that we have in the world.
And they're continuously
functioning,
and they have that relative
degree of stability
that states don't have.
So I see the Middle East is
capable of-- it certainly
has the money to do so--
capable of building itself
into an connected,
inter-urban sort of system.
And I hope that that's where
the investment from the outside
and from within the
Arab world can go.
So the geopolitics we can
talk about with Yasmin
because that's a
specialty of hers as well.
This is one of my favorites.
I'm going to show
you one or two more.
This is five billion people or
so, give or take, on this map.
Most of the world's
population is in Eurasia.
Just India and
China alone, to say
nothing of Southeast
Asia and the Middle East
and so forth--
you've got literally
almost five billion people.
So eastern Eurasia is
a world unto itself.
And you certainly heard in 2015
about the Asia Infrastructure
and Investment Bank, which
is going to be putting up
$150 billion and more with
many countries participating
to build infrastructure
across Eurasia.
And in fact, that process
already began 25 years ago.
The Soviet Union collapsed
in the early 1990s,
and ever since then, China has
begun this process of building
railways, highways,
pipelines, electricity
grids, water canals, and so
forth to link up Eurasia.
Now, why is it doing that?
Well, China has more neighbors
than any country in the world.
China has 14 neighbors.
It doesn't want to fight
a war with any of them.
In fact, every
neighbor of China is
suspicious of China
for good reason.
So what China
does-- I like to use
this analogy from the
construction industry--
it's going to build, own,
and operate its neighbors.
What do contractors do?
They build, they
own, they operate.
So China isn't going to
invade its neighbors,
because that will obviously
heighten tensions even further.
But it's just going to
build its way across them.
And it's going to do so to
achieve the supply chain world.
It's going to smooth the
inflow of commodities
and raw materials that
it needs, and it's
going to smooth the outflow--
the export-- of the electronics
and other goods that
it manufactures.
And to do so, its
infrastructurally
reorganizing all of Eurasia.
So the lives of
five billion people
are being touched by this
Chinese activity that
began 25 years ago and is
accelerating every single year.
So I think of AIIB-- the Asian
Infrastructure and Investment
Bank-- I think of it as the
NATO of the 21st century.
And that's
instructive because we
think of security as being the
world's paramount public good.
The United States is the
foremost provider of it,
especially since World War II.
But along comes China
and says, well, there's
another global public good
as important as security.
It is infrastructure.
It is connectivity.
Every country seems to want
it because 60 or 70 countries
lined up to join this bank as
soon as it was established.
And China is going to
be the world's largest
provider of this.
So the NATO of the 21st
century is the AIIB,
and it's a world in which
people crave and need
that connectivity and
infrastructure as much
as they want security.
So another couple of maps.
Aha, this one.
This is another one that
Canadians may not like so much
or they may find interesting.
If our climate change
projections are correct--
and this is a map that was
made by the British journal
the New Scientist-- they said
if the world temperatures rise
four degrees Celsius
above the 1990 baseline
that the IPCC uses, where will
the world's food production be?
And so what you find if their
extrapolation is correct
and the impact that
this temperature rise
is going to have in terms
of wiping out the food
production in what our today
some of the world's most
significant bread baskets--
the world's largest food
producers are the United
States, Brazil, India, China,
Australia, and a
couple other countries.
So notice those countries
are all now pasty brown.
They've all been
desertified, if you will.
And a food production
will happen
in areas that have traditionally
been tundra and Arctic, which
is to say Canada and Russia.
But what are the two
largest countries
in the world and two of the
most depopulated countries
in the world?
Russia and Canada.
So here you have
a situation where
the geography of the world's
population today, which
is almost everyone south
of the Arctic Circle--
66 degrees north latitude.
Do you know how many people live
north of the Arctic Circle ring
today?
It's less than the
population of Manhattan.
It's less than
four million people
who live in the
entire Arctic Circle.
And yet, we're heading to a
world where most of the food
is supposedly going to
be coming from there.
That requires us to think pretty
differently about the world
than just nations and borders.
We have to think
about food supply
chains and mass migrations
and new kinds of settlements.
And this is just the final nail
in the coffin in the argument.
As if the internet and
connectivity and infrastructure
and economies and
migration weren't enough
cause to believe that the
world is reorganizing itself,
here's the icing on the cake.
We will just have to.
And this is even absent
rising sea levels
and coastal inundations and
potential tsunamis having
a devastating impact on the
world's coastal megacities,
particularly in Asia.
So we could be in for, obviously
a stormy and turbulent time--
people always talk about that.
But think about the
consequences for what
we do the next day and the
next day and the next day.
And it's going to
require rethinking
how we organize ourselves.
And that's what
this is all about.
So I'm probably going
to stop right there.
I'm just wondering if there's
one pretty map I can end on.
Oh, of course, it's this one.
We might toggle between
this and the next one a lot
since we're here at Google--
a foremost technology company.
What I got TeleGeography
to do for me
here is to map out
bandwidth speeds
within and across the continents
and to update their data.
So you can get a sense of where
global connectivity is going.
Because, of course, the value of
the services trade in the world
system is now greater than
the value of goods trade.
And Google is, of
course, part of making
that happen with things
like the fiber one cable
and even the cables
that are being laid down
across the continental
United States
and providing faster bandwidth
to American communities.
This gives you a sense of
how much more we have to go.
Because you can see that even
though the populations that
are online in Asia are so
significant and even Africa,
the percentage of the
populations that are online
is still not where it could be.
So in India and China, it's
hovering around 40 to 50
to 60 percent.
So not at the
level where you see
Western Europe and
the United States
and Japan and South Korea
where it's 100% or more.
So this is, I know, a mission
that a lot of key technology
companies play.
And having traveled
around and looked so much
at the catalytic impact
that connectivity has,
whether it's energy,
transportation,
or communications,
I strongly believe
in that connectivity mission.
There's all this good
stuff about genetics too
which is in the
book, but we'll just
leave up this peaceful map of
the world's intercity networks.
And we'll invite
Yasmin back up and we
can talk about maybe some
of the other maps as well.
Thank you so much,
it's really a pleasure
to be here, especially today.
YASMIN: That was a
fascinating presentation.
I didn't want it to end.
And I think you went
in the right direction
with pretty pictures--
we like maps.
We like data at Google.
So we have 20 minutes.
I thought maybe I
could steal 10 minutes
to ask you a few questions
that are burning on my mind,
and then we can have 10
minutes of Q&A with the people
who are with us.
I thought I'd start with cities.
You've been thinking
about cities for longer
than most other people I know.
You've been talking about
cities for a long time--
before it was cool.
PARAG KHANNA: Now it's
not even cool anymore.
YASMIN: It's very cool.
It's very hot.
Megacities and megalopises--
would that be the plural?
Megalopoli.
PARAG KHANNA:
Let's go with that.
YASMIN: I was wondering if you
could tell us a little bit more
about how you
think about cities.
And we do, being part of Google
and part of the tech sector,
we do think a lot
about China and the US.
We compare China's approach
and the US's approach
to governance and to
structure and to strategy.
So I wonder if you could
tell us a bit more about how
you think the Chinese
and the Americans are
thinking about cities?
PARAG KHANNA: Sure.
And we shouldn't
forget the Europeans.
Because Europe has
centuries of history
and is pedestrian,
walkable, dense,
and mid-size urban
environments that
are actually more sustainable.
So China has obviously
vastly overshot
that given its huge population.
It's gone out of its
way to build these more
gigantic industrial sites.
But then again, it's still an
industrial society or economy,
whereas the Western world
is more post-industrial.
So China takes a lot of its
inspiration, I would say,
or its efforts
today from Europe,
which is to say how to implement
more sustainable technologies
in these urban environments
that they realize
have become horribly congested
and polluted and so forth.
What you find in
these Chinese clusters
is that you'll have one or
two or three core cities,
and then each of those will
have little satellite towns
and then each of them will be
connected by high-speed railway
networks and highways.
And then each of those
clusters, like I said,
is connected to
the other clusters.
So you get really this
crystalline kind of structure.
And that is how it's emerging.
Now, in the US, there's
no such strategy behind--
YASMIN: Because there's
a strategy with China.
That's the point you're making?
PARAG KHANNA: It is a strategy.
So urbanization is an organic
phenomenon around the world.
It's one of these
irrevocable megatrends
in the same connectivity is.
The way I put it, there's
two irrevocable megatrends
across time and history today.
One is this connectivity, and
the other is urbanization.
You bring the two
together, and you've
get this map of the world.
So around the world, people
organically, voluntarily
are flooding into cities.
China is the only place where
it's happening both voluntarily
and involuntarily because
they're dictating and directing
and steering people
into new cities
that they've built
that are empty.
There've been a lot
of media reports that
call them ghost towns.
But then you go back
after four or five years
and they're starting to fill
up because people are looking
to move out of places
that have been wiped out
as the manufacturing sector has
collapsed, wages have risen.
So they're moving
into these new towns.
And a city, to remain
economically viable in terms
of its services sector or
having a resilient services
economy, versus being dependent
on manufacturing exports that
are highly volatile, you need
to have at least three to four
million people various
research suggests.
So the problem with
many American cities
is that their populations
are below a million people.
So you take Detroit.
Detroit's population fell
to below a million people,
and it lacked that internally
resilient services economy
that would allow it to sustain
itself beyond export oriented
automobile industry.
So we need to re-aggregate
our cities in a way
that they can be
internally viable.
And so the way I
describe Detroit's future
in this New York Time's
piece is that it should
be seen as the midway point
on a Chicago-Toronto corridor
within this broader
North American Union.
That's just not the way
Congresspeople think.
I mean, we are a long, long
way from our Congress, which
of course everything
is about fighting
for fiscal and budgetary
scraps to go into your state,
not caring about whether
or not that infrastructure
or connectivity stretches across
one state boundary to another
so that you can
mutually benefit.
We are down here when it
comes to the sophistication
of our political
logic and stretching
beyond our state boundaries.
Meanwhile, what I'm proposing
is it makes total sense.
Just look at a map.
Chicago, Toronto,
Detroit in the middle,
you should be having a
trade and industry corridor.
That's an export
powerhouse taking
advantage of Arctic shipping
routes through Hudson Bay.
In Washington, they can't
even find Hudson Bay on a map
and I wish I weren't
exaggerating,
but that's where we need to be.
An even second tier Chinese
cities you can go to,
they've all got their
own economic master
plans and strategies--
what industries
they want to attract, what
companies are they targeting,
what supply chains do
they want to be part of.
All of these things they're
thinking way, way, way ahead.
Now, there are a
number of cities
that are starting to do
this like Columbus, Ohio,
and Salt Lake City and
the Brookings Institution
as a whole department
that consults on this.
It's starting, but that doesn't
mean it's going to succeed.
Just like in China or
other places in the world,
cities get wiped out.
Industries rise and fall.
People have to move.
The beautiful thing I would
say about America-- the virtue,
the luck, the manifest destiny,
whatever you want to call it--
is that America is so large,
so devolved, so federalized, so
distributed, has so many
large population centers
that people can re-sort when you
have these economic convulsions
like we've been having.
And it's one of the
things that people
have to take advantage of.
The history of
American migration
is searching for opportunity
in new geographies,
and so I think that great
re-sorting as some economists
and sociologists
call it is actually
underway today in America.
It may seem tragic and painful
to see the lack of opportunity
in many areas and the
fact that people just
have to just get up and go.
But that's actually part
of American history,
and think about
all the countries
where you don't have
that possibility, where
the entire economy centers
around one city and nothing
else.
And if that city fails,
if that economy fails,
if the one industry
that drives it fails,
the whole country is screwed.
That's never going
to happen to America.
And America is lucky,
but it should actually
build the infrastructure to
make it more possible for people
to make those moves today that
are necessary to revitalize
society and the economy.
YASMIN: You spoke about
cities being the only thing
that you can see from
space and the thing
that we've had for 5,000
years as well-- the nation
states in the Westphalian
system are 200 years old.
Let's imagine that the
megacity model in China
and exporting it and
say that Congress
adopts your prescriptions in
your New York Times op ed,
what does this mean
for the nation state
and also for national identity?
Many Americans,
Europeans, Canadians
enjoy their sense of
national identity.
What happens when
the city takes over
as the atom and
the building block?
PARAG KHANNA: So
history is cumulative,
it's not substitutive.
Nothing that I've
said at any point
should suggest that nations
and states and boundaries
and national
governments disappear.
We're always going to live
in some country or the other.
The entire world's
physical geography
is claimed by sovereign states.
In fact, there are
many geographies that
are claimed by multiple states.
You will always be standing
on the territory that
belongs to or is claimed
by a sovereign government.
I've got no problem with that.
But history is additive.
It's the cities from
5,000 years ago,
it's the empires
that have existed
for thousands of years--
America is an empire.
Europe has empires.
The European Union is an empire.
China is an empire.
India is an empire.
And then you have the
states that are now
another layer on top of that.
So you have sovereignty,
you have enlightenment,
you have technology,
you have capitalism,
you have infrastructure--
all these things just
keep on and on layering.
So the city doesn't
replace the country anymore
than the country ever
replaced the city.
These things just make the
world more complicated.
And that complexity applies
to all of us in our identity
as well.
If you were never able
to connect to anyone
outside your
national boundaries,
if you had no access to
information, if you couldn't
leave the country in
which you were born,
you would have a relatively
limited selection
of identities to choose from--
that which is prescribed
by the king, that
which is prescribed
by the pope, whatever
the case may be.
That's not the case anymore.
And so what I find,
especially in a world that
is very young-- I mean 40%,
50% of the world's population
is young and youthful, and
a large share of the world's
population is also old.
But when I travel around and
I talk to young people, what
I find is not a sense
that national identity
is the only identity
that matters to them.
It's not something you
have to reject in order
to appreciate and
absorb and embrace
the multitude of identities.
So I talk in this
book about civicism,
which is a new-ish term
coined by a friend of mine,
in which he says the pride
and loyalty in a city.
Of course, if you're
New Yorker like I am,
you're a New Yorker first.
YASMIN: How old were you
when you moved to New York?
PARAG KHANNA: I was six.
YASMIN: So you get to
say you're a New Yorker?
PARAG KHANNA: Yeah.
YASMIN: No one disputes
that your a New Yorker.
PARAG KHANNA: They dare not.
YASMIN: Because I
wonder how long it would
take me to be a New Yorker.
PARAG KHANNA: Let me just
say something about this.
This a city-- right now in
Albany and elsewhere, they're
actually discussing
whether or not
to give migrants and
non-citizens voting
rights in municipal elections.
So vote for mayor of New
York or in city council
ballots and referendum.
I think that's awesome.
Obviously, you're a New
Yorker if you're able to vote.
You could be someone who
is not even naturalized.
You could be an illegal
alien who is just
in some way given
some identity card
and you might be
able to participate
in the politics of the state.
You will not be voting for
president for a very long time,
but the politics of the city,
you're going to be part of.
I think that's incredible.
Only cities like
Rotterdam and Toronto
and Hamburg and New
York and other places
are actually starting to
do that kind of thing,
because they say--
like ancient Athens,
by the way, just going back
to the history of cities,
where there any
resident of Athens
was part of the
polity of Athens.
And there's nothing so radical
of that coming back today.
One of the biggest
sections in the book
is actually about devolution.
It's about cities and provinces
reclaiming their right
to govern themselves.
Because that's where
the decisions are made,
that's where lives are
affected, that's why mayors
are becoming so powerful.
That's why when
someone like Bloomberg
entertains running
for president,
so many people
take it seriously.
That's why there are more
president's today-- active,
sitting, serving
presidents today--
whose last job was
mayor of a big city
than ever before in history.
Because that's the stepping
stone of proving you actually
know how to run something.
So civicism is one new kind of
identity beyond your national
or government identity
or religious identity.
And then there's
all the identities
that you acquire
through technology.
The whole field of social
physics, as it's called,
is about understanding
how people now
form these cloud communities.
What is your identity
in the cloud?
Not just what's
your avatar's name,
but how do you feel
about the communities
that you're part of online.
People who have a certain cause.
Arab democracy,
environmentalism, you name it.
That identity can
be very strong, too.
And so I don't think that one
has to substitute the other.
We have to embrace
this complexity.
Each of us has many
identities that overlap.
YASMIN: Yeah, that's
a really nice point.
We have less than 10 minutes,
so I will allow anyone here
to ask a question now.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for coming.
I have a question-- kind
of a counter-view on this.
I was thinking that you've
mentioned the maps in terms
of the city and linking
the cities and the cities
growing and encompassing
the core of connectivity.
People and pipelines and
infrastructure and electricity.
I have a counter-view.
I was thinking in terms of
things are dilluting away
from cities in the sense that
given that connectivity has
reached every part, everyone
has a phone now, even
in India near my small
city where I was born.
And now even
[INAUDIBLE] has a phone.
He doesn't earn enough,
but he has phone.
So that means that everyone, if
they wish, can learn and become
of service-- can
trade their services.
So that means we don't really
need them to come to services.
So people should
go away from cities
and start-- I should see
a more uniform lighted
map, which I was kind of
hoping to see in the book.
Maybe all the bulbs
should light up everywhere
and then it would
be homogenized.
The other one I was thinking was
that the four degree centigrade
increase where most of
South America and India
was flooded and gone,
that seems to me
that don't they have
mud in the Himalayas?
Can't they carry and
put them on the sides
and then they stop the water
from [INAUDIBLE] New York City?
Keep dumping mud
from Central America
on the sides of New York City.
They built Dubai just by
shoving mud into water.
PARAG KHANNA: It was a little
more complicated than that,
but that said, land
reclamation is actually
one of the themes in this book.
I talk about sand--
the role of sand.
There's this global
market for sand
that gets shipped and
towed all over the world
to build up artificial islands.
So obviously, you
see this happening
in the South China Sea.
And I actually say,
think about how much
the United States spends
on missiles and submarines
and aircraft carriers and
fighter jets and so forth
and China is using
sand-- silica--
the most abundant element
in the earth's crust.
It's free.
It's now the most powerful
geopolitical weapon.
China just takes this
sand, dumps it onto rocks,
and is able to claim new
political sovereignty
in very sensitive environments.
So it's a lesson lesson.
But let me take
your first question.
I've heard this many times.
If all it took to convince
people not to move to cities
is to give them even a
solar-power-charged mobile
phone, then I don't know why
they would move to cities.
And the truth is you
don't just move to a city
because you really want
to get a Nokia phone.
You go there for health
care, you go there for jobs,
you go there for education, you
go there for basic services,
for income, to send
remittances back,
to experience modern
life, which are things
that you're not going to get.
You're talking
about connectivity
as if it's just
digital connectivity,
but the fact is that
the incidence of malaria
falls drastically if you
have a hardwood or concrete
floor in your home, which many
billions of people do not have.
A mobile phone is not the same.
A mobile phone does
not cure malaria.
So you will, as I say,
never ever stop people
from moving to cities.
Ever.
There's nothing you can say.
There's no amount of fiber
cable Google or anyone else
can lay down to the remote
villages, where of course
it makes no economic
sense to lay down cables
to because there's no one there.
You will never
stop urbanization.
Only massive, massive
tsunamis drowning the billions
of people urbanizing
on the Pacific Rim
is going to stop urbanization.
So you can't convince people
that just because they
have a bunch of phones
in rural environments
that life is better
where they are.
Because if that were true,
they wouldn't be coming.
Again, this is a
voluntary process,
and it is as much or more
so in India than anywhere
else in the world.
Of course, the most
rapidly urbanizing country
on the planet is India, even
though they have exponentially
accelerating mobile
phone penetration.
AUDIENCE: My
question is slightly
different from this one.
Is it right to say that we are
just becoming one civilization?
If yes, then historically,
civilizations,
they end up collapsing,
and most of the time,
in a spectacular fashion.
What makes us different?
PARAG KHANNA: On the
question of civilization,
I think it is the
first time when
you can speak of something
like this global network
civilization.
It's not a terminology that
we could've used before.
But civilization in the sense
of those that rise and decline
as you say in these
spectacular moments
of collapse, that tends to be
an anthropological, ecological,
and political
pattern with respect
to specific geographic
cultural civilizations.
I'm using civilization
in a much looser
sense of the ability
for mankind to have
a certain minimal degree of
connectivity amongst its parts
so that you can think of it as
having some kind of a cohesion.
You never would have
been able to say
that many generations ago
or certainly centuries
ago-- the notion that
we are all in this boat
together, so to speak.
You didn't hear people exactly
talking like that in the 19th
and even in the 20th centuries.
So that's the sense in
which I mean civilization.
And of course,
again, a lot of it
rests on this physical
connectedness.
You can't influence and
you have much less sympathy
for that which you
can't touch and feel,
that which you're
not connected to.
One of the examples
I give in the book
is the collapse of that
garment factory in Bangladesh
in the year 2013 where there was
an uproar for months and months
and years because there
was a Bangladeshi garment
factory making clothing
for Western retailers.
There was this uproar
saying H&M and Zara
and these other companies,
what are you doing about this?
What are you doing about
the plight of those people?
I mean, can you imagine that
happening even 10 years ago,
15 years ago?
No way.
It's because the supply
chain connects us here
in rich New York to the
poorest people in the world.
And so we're able to have some
degree of sympathy or empathy
with them.
That never, ever, ever
could have been the case.
And previously, if
it were the case--
the anti-slavery
movement, for example--
it was obviously more emotive
and more geographically
specific.
But now, you can find
these connections
through the supply chain
between almost any two people
in the world.
And again, that process is
just now getting underway.
YASMIN: Final closing note.
I wonder if you could say
something that speaks maybe
to-- you are here at
Google-- maybe to those of us
in the tech sector who think
about connectivity probably
in only one aspect of the
way that you tackle it
in this book.
But the tech sector is
thinking about driver-less cars
and aerial delivery systems and
AI and automated assistance.
We're laying down cables.
We're big on connectivity.
What would you leave us with as
the promise or the opportunity
for technology's role
in connectography?
PARAG KHANNA: So I
point out in the book
that telecom companies,
technology companies,
are infrastructure companies.
And obviously, Google
is foremost among them
in terms of literally
contributing
to this physical, built
infrastructural environment,
to which I say amen.
Because we're
desperately lagging
in that category across the
board of, again, energy,
transportation,
communications-- what's
called the infrastructure
stock has been so meager
for a world of nine
billion people.
So Google, as well as
very large companies
like pipeline companies
and railway companies,
are all agents of connectivity.
And so they're actually, in a
way, the heroes of this book
are those that facilitate,
enable, and expand connectivity
because we have been able
to demonstrate as far
back as the
Industrial Revolution
that it is connectivity has
lifted global living standards,
that has enhanced trade.
There've been enough Nobel
Prizes given out for this,
by the way, going back to
like Michael Spence, Angus
Deaton, Robert Solow-- you
can't disprove the notion
that connectivity is the agent
of growth in the world economy.
And it's all forms
of connectivity.
So even if governments
aren't doing it,
if the private sector is, I
think that's a fantastic thing.
And that's not just for
countries, that's for people.
We can measure now
everything from how
your labor productivity improves
by being digitally connected.
We know that in terms of the
workforce around the world.
So in every way,
connectivity is not
only something that has this
empirical role in strengthening
our capacity and
our productivity,
but it really should
be a human right.
In this book, connectivity
is presented as a human right
as much as anything.
Connectivity and
mobility should really
be considered two of the
absolute foremost human rights
in the world.
And I can't think of any
instance in which it is not
a good thing for a human
being to have an option
to be more connected
and more mobile.
And so if you want to talk
about improving mankind's fate,
you definitely want to extend
that connectivity to everyone
you can.
So congrats for doing so.
YASMIN: Wonderful note
to round off the talk.
Thank you very
much, Parag Khanna.
PARAG KHANNA: Thank you.